ballerina Misty Copeland dazzles
audiences like here in the ballet Gisele
she became the first black woman to get
promoted to principal dancer at American
Ballet Theater in 2015. her new book is
called the wind at my back resilience
Grace and the other gifts from my mentor
Raven Wilkinson Copeland writes about
her own path in lessons she learned from
Wilkinson a black ballerina in the 1950s
and 60s whose career was derailed by
racism Misty Copeland joins us now good
morning how you doing good morning I'm
so excited to be here I'm glad you're
here now you didn't learn about Raven
Wilkinson until you were well into your
career how did you learn about it I was
being a bun head that's what we call
them a bun head you know I was I was
doing my research in history just
wanting to learn more about
um the world that I was a part of
because ballerina is where the Buns yes
yes it is you know kind of like being a
nerd I guess and I was watching um a
documentary called the ballet roosta
Monte Carlo about the company
um and you know more than halfway into
this documentary this black elegant
woman comes onto the screen and it just
stopped me in my tracks because I had no
idea that a black woman existed in that
company she was the first and only black
woman to dance with the company I didn't
know anything about her and my initial
reaction was recognition I could see
myself in her and the power of
representation it's it's so important
and then
I was angry because I didn't I how could
I not know about her especially being
the only black woman at ABT you know for
the first 10 years of my career you know
it just made me frustrated that our
history is not documented and it's often
erased as as black people especially in
America and then Misty you get to meet
her and you two become Incredibly Close
yes what was that like for you getting
to know her and I wonder what it was
like the first time she saw you dance I
would be so intimidated by that it would
be like cooking to me for Julia a child
why did you two because you two became
very close yeah well I um my manager
Gilda Squire she actually did the she
went and found out where she was living
and we found out she was living a block
away from me
it was stunning and then I found out
that she had been attending all of my
performances since I joined the company
when I was 17 years I didn't have that
moment of oh my gosh Raven's coming to
watch me for the first time she'd
already been watching me yeah in
incredible but when you know she was in
the audience when I knew she was in the
audience it was this amazing support and
you know getting to know her
um she just gave me a different sense of
belonging and purpose than I had before
because you said you said she supported
you not only as a dancer but as a woman
yes to have to watch her journey and see
that so much hasn't changed or hadn't
changed in 50 years between our careers
um made me want to push even harder to
be able to continue on and and go into
spaces and do roles that she never got
an opportunity to to dance and not just
her so many black ballerinas throughout
history and and Raven just became as she
said the wind at my back and that's what
she would say to me before every
performance and to this day I still have
those voicemails saved where she would
say whenever you go onto the stage let
me be the wind at your back I'm going to
be there so you can hear her voice wow
so meeting Raven must have been a
life-changing experience let's go to
another life-changing experience
becoming a parent a mother your son is
not seven months old yeah we can call
you Jackson's mom oh I love that how did
that change you
um I feel like it's it's made me step
back from myself uh you know as a dancer
as an artist as an athlete as a
performer so much of our time is focused
on us and putting you know the work into
our bodies and Recovery whatever it is
it's it's so focused on you and to have
to step back and worry about this other
little being
that's completely just changed I don't
know the way that I look at
um the time and you know yes there's
time that I have to give to myself and
and focus but maybe not so much
a balance it's been all about you know
finding a balance but I can't wait to go
back on stage with this new perspective
of having this incredible Love Is that
what's going to go back on stage yeah
that so we're looking at the winter of
2023. okay
yeah well Misty Copeland thank you so
much for joining us congratulations on
everything in the new book The Wind at
my back goes on sale tomorrow